the government and people want to play
Minority Report they want to stop the
crime before it happens you can't do
that it doesn't actually work oh but
it's coming Theo yeah I know the AI chat
gp7 whatever is gonna probably do it but
it's not practical and it's not going to
work and it's only going to cause and
we've seen this up north where red flag
loss have gotten innocent people killed
where they show up to the doorstep the
guy comes out there's an altercation
he's like why are you guys here I
haven't done Community crimes yet ends
up getting shot there's been at least
two of those uh that have happened
um it's going to do more harm than good
and besides that according to all these
shootings have happened at least in the
last like five years uh supposedly the
FBI already knew about the person yeah
they're constantly already watching them
so it's like well it obviously doesn't
work already I mean you guys have been
trying to do this kind of the API tries
to prevent crimes right they're just
aware stuff is going on but they're like
maybe we'll help you assist do that
crime